hey guys happy vlogmas so I just wanted
to tell you really really quick because
December 22nd is the deadline for the
grandparents gone wired campaign and I
just wanted to make sure that you guys
got an opportunity to participate
dosomething.org is one of my favorite
organizations that I've had the
opportunity to work with in the past
they're so awesome and they're so nice
and I love this campaign because I love
technology obviously and my grandmother
is so tech savvy
she has Twitter she's Facebook she's
Instagram she's she has it all which is
why I love this campaign so I wanted to
show you guys this really fun little I
guess it's like a PSA we've got in the
past couple of years here in my
apartment on a green screen but this
year we went to a studio and we shot it
and it was really really fun a great
update doesn't fight much crime no worry
my carrier pigeon is now and I carry
your pigeon and I just got an email
but she's connecting older adults to new
technology through do something that
boards grandparents Don wired campaign
powered by mentor up I sundial
wait this is a right team up with the
great update text wired to three eight
three eight three and teach new
technology to local seniors you don't
have to be super just
superfish any cause anytime anywhere I
hope you guys enjoy bat I hope you guys
have been enjoying vlogmas it's been so
much fun vlogging with you guys I don't
know what I'm gonna do after the 25th
are you gonna miss me do you think I
should still vlog what should I do
I like kind of mixing up the vlogs with
actual videos although I haven't had
enough time to really make the videos I
wanted to do I had a bunch of really
great cooking ideas that I wanted to
make for the holidays didn't get a
chance to do that cuz uh well my
apartments been falling apart
the downstairs flooded I don't think I
even posted that vlog yet oh my god it's
it's something else I think we'll just
go into that vlog since I haven't posted
it yet here it is my house falling apart
and my sister trying to help me organize
my life oh that um actually so this
works with a GPS so this this is hooked
up to a GPS so I can put in an address
and it'll take me there and the lights
will light up there in a bit go this way
go that way and when I arrive to the
situation it'll start blinking so right
now who here are having a really big
struggle for somebody who is not a
fashion guru or a beauty guru on YouTube
I sure have a lot of makeup and crap so
we're doing some serious holiday
donating of the clothing um I also do
you remember when you told me that I
wasn't allowed to buy any more flannel
no I did listen but this is all the old
school like Hello yeah do you want it
but it's always nice because we get to
like take all these clothes and donate
them and and then get to go to good
homes so that's always nice it does look
really cute
how's my hair is it look nice today sure
does
I had my shirt on backwards what time is
it that's my shirt 1234 I think it's
probably just your shirt so we've got a
problem in our apartment since all the
rain has been happening there's water
damage like the roof is leaking and it's
now leaking down into
this closet so I gotta get all this
stuff out of here did you find it I was
just about to do find my freaking iPhone
guys this place is a mess like the house
is falling apart the roof is linking the
they've got I got to show you this did
you see what's happening downstairs oh
come look this is an episode of Hoarders
we're here with our Justine Justine he's
Eric she's here she's living like a hog
we've got this big fan
I just go back this is not this is this
is like a big problem and obviously it's
not my house
so the landlord has to deal with all
this crap that's what I'm afraid about
like buying a house is doing household
duties of which I know nothing about
yeah so big fan
it's real see I look at you well by
doing your job alright so time to gonna
take this CFX hmm like I'm having so
much fun right now I've been waiting to
do this for over a year over a year Jen
dude
one good push is all tanks jeez he's
still pushing oh man you're in a hurry
bro hey Justine you wanna hang out early
now
all really good news they originally
told me that my computer was gonna have
to stay there overnight they have to
order a new hard drive because a lot
they fixed it they fixed it so now I'm
going to go and pick it up and I'm gonna
be able to have my baby back for planing
judge
it's actually really exciting for an
entire year I've been running that
computer off of an external hard drive
so now I will actually be able to use my
computer like an actual computer you
know yeah you know you know Julie out is
quite chilly out
we're on the third floor what crumble
look at her she looks so pretty we're
gonna put her back into the corner
look at these cords like this is this is
a I don't even know if this is safe I'm
not sure don't care anyway I'll see you
guys tomorrow
uh we're uh I don't know whatever know
what day it is today because vlogmas has
just been uh I don't know haven't been
posting my videos in order good thing I
have this massive studio light that I
use to light my apartment so really
great all right guys we'll see you
tomorrow happy vlogmas bye Jen bye bye
bye to my vlog
oh my you guys can go watch whatever
happened to y'all's on my channel oh
sure sounds good bye you know me late in
the description of course they roll it
you're gonna put it on yeah